laughs as you guys may know as a brother
explained is what I came to Islam in
2012 the matter which we're going to be
talking about today is the matter of
Xena
this matter is something that I'm really
really passionate about and the reason
why I'm so passionate about is some some
of you guys might might know and some of
you guys might not know in jahiliya I've
lost family members to dinner and I've
had a cousin that committed suicide
because of Xena I father my cousin's
friend who killed himself about three
months later hanged himself in a park
because of Xena I had my neighbor who
also killed himself because of Xena
unfortunately community that I come from
is very lost and what llahi sometimes
when I look at born Muslims and I just
feel like expressing myself how blessed
they are to have Islam because when I
look at the youth in my community
wallahi by Allah they so lost and
obviously it's a passionate topic for me
I don't want to waste the time because
we've got some really important
questions that we want to talk about and
what like it's a great honor for me to
be with like like right now you've seen
right next to miss I can't explain to
you may Allah bless brother multi-bank
I've learned manners how to be humble
how to get rid of my arrogance by
watching these videos may Allah wants
our grant in Jannah I'm not going to
carry on any further because the topics
are very important and inshallah we're
gonna get straight with it inshallah
she's a communicator
bismillahir-rahmanir-rahim to begin with
Salaam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuhu once again SMIL ar-rahman
ar-rahim alhamdulillah wa salatu wa
salam o allah rasool allah wa ala aalihi
wa sahbihi wa many dead a buddha who
were bad it was such an honor to have
met brother ali yesterday for the first
time and al hamdulillah some of you who
might be on snapchat or Instagram might
have seen the post he posted and just a
quick clarification I see
a little bit nervous maybe am I am i
right yeah slightly nervous or you've
got over it okay that's good but I can
just say something quickly we're all
human beings we're all trying to help
one another I'm sure you guys make do
alpha me as well what I'd like to let
you know is yesterday we were trying to
take a picture so as I was you know
pressing the screen I noticed this white
light from it you guys probably know
those who have iPhones I said it earlier
but I'm repeating it because the man is
here okay so what happened is he said
that's a video so I said oh
salaam-alaikum and whatever whatever I
said and that went viral if I'm not
mistaken
anyway that's okay we're speaking about
zina for those who don't know what it
means it's talking of adultery or
fornication sexual misconduct
misbehavior now to begin with Allah has
made marriage very easy and Allah has
facilitated it it's so simple if you
think it's difficult it's because of
something that's holding you down
that's not Allah that's what it is it's
not Islam it's not Allah it's not the
rule of Allah it's something else that's
holding you back holding you down
prohibiting stopping putting obstacles
it can never be allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala so Allah has made it easy so
that no one has an excuse to say I
committed adultery it's one of the
kaabah it it's one of the major sins it
removes the note from the face of an
individual and it removes the happiness
and contentment from the life of an
individual and it takes away the chances
of you or me or anyone else going into
paradise with ease so it's not like you
won't enter paradise may allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala grant us all paradise but you
need to seek forgiveness you need to
make amends you need to become once
again a person who's asked Allah
forgiveness and said look I've done
whatever I've done in the past it's over
it's gone I don't want Shaitaan to bog
me down I started a new life and oh
Allah forgive me grant me paradise once
you're genuine and sincere
do not let Shaitaan make you go back to
think about what happened and destroy
your future because one of share plans
plans is he makes you lose hope losing
hope in the sense that Oh someone comes
and says you know I've committed
adultery or fornication or I've cheated
and I've done this and that and I made
Toba but you know it's eating me alive I
can't read Salah anymore I feel too
dirty
that's shape on the first part of it was
the mercy of Allah that made you turn to
Allah but the second part of it is the
devil making you think hang on hang on
hang on Allah won't forgive you no way
you went a little bit too far you know
no matter what you've done remember that
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala will forgive
you listen to these beautiful verses
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala says one
Lavina either follow fahisha tan
for Sehun duck out on law if I still
follow they don't know being in why my
feelings gonna be in love more
all while mu Salama fine waiata moon
hola in cages MOC or to me roar beam
wasn't
amazing allies saying those who have
transgressed against themselves
committed immorality those who have
engaged in immoral acts and this
includes adultery fornication and
everything we're speaking about this
evening in terms of sin those who have
engaged in immoral acts or they have
oppressed themselves remember Allah and
seek forgiveness and who is there to
forgive besides Allah
you know what allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
says if they do not continue in their
bad ways which means if they've turned
and they've changed their lives and they
know that they have actually turned for
the sake of Allah they don't knowingly
go back and commit the sin Allah says
for them is forgiveness and paradise so
Allah is talking about those who did
commit the sin that hang on there's a
way to get to paradise and that is mend
your ways forget about the past by
seeking forgiveness don't just say okay
I was bad now I'm good ask Allah's
forgiveness I was bad oh Allah forgive
me now I'm good and then don't lose hope
I've come across so many people and I'm
sure Ali we had a chat just before the
session and we were exchanging notes and
he was telling me that a lot of people
ask about halal dating for example and I
was busy telling him you know the dates
that I know that are purely halala from
madina munawwara those are the ones
really they have chocolate-coated they
now have strawberry they have so much
those are halal dates my brothers and
sisters really halal dates you know them
you know them mashallah have our okama
but anyway we'll get to that halal
dating what I'm saying right now is of
utmost importance and that is brothers
and sisters what you've done cannot be
undone except through Toba that's it
when you engage in Toba it is undone
when we say undone listen to another
verse Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala speaks
about zina and major sins in surat
al-furqan towards the end and Allah
speaks about major sins and then he says
those people who engage
major sins will be punished but he makes
an exception because he's so merciful
and he says in da Boa a Minami lamellar
Solihull fur
Iike you bandino long sahi a team hasana
but what can a llama for him the
exception is of those who have repented
to allah subhanahu wata'ala and after
that done good deeds Allah sees for them
we will convert the bad deeds undone
isn't it we were speaking about undoing
bad deeds we will convert the bad deeds
by bringing them onto the right side of
the scale into good deeds because they
change their lives after they asked
Allah forgiveness so if you ask her loss
forgiveness from a sin he will forgive
you and he will wipe the sin out and if
you commit the sin again you ask alice
forgiveness again he will forgive you he
will wipe this in and if you commit the
sin a third time you ask Allah
forgiveness and the conditions are admit
your sin regret it ask allah's
forgiveness and promised not to do it
again if those conditions are met its
wiped out gone don't doubt the
forgiveness of Allah don't ever don't
allow Japan to come to you and make you
think you know what I'm not forgiving if
those four conditions were met you are
forgiven so some might ask what if after
some time I committed it again because
you know I happen to fall although when
I engaged in Toba I was genuine well if
you were genuine be genuine once again
and genuine a third time and genuine up
to the time you die if if the sin was
repeated without having planned it at
the time of your previous Toba do you
know what you will still be deserving of
the mercy of Allah that Toba is
acceptable but one is for your talbott
to be accepted in a way that the sin is
wiped out the other is for your tower to
be accepted and your sin is converted to
a good deed when will that be when you
have changed your life that's the
condition and done only good deeds
thereafter avoided major sin thereafter
then you are owed something else because
you know once you sin you sin once you
regret that feeling of regret is a sign
of Eman sign of belief when you commit
the same sin again your regret is a
little bit less third time it's less
four or five six seven times it becomes
a habit you start enjoying committing a
sin and this is why if you can ask Allah
forgiveness
quit knowing that you can do it but
you're not doing it for the sake of
Allah Allah says you know what you
deserve that that bad deed becomes a
good deed you know why because you could
have done it but you didn't because you
want to please Allah so this is just the
introduction I started with it I took a
bit of time with it but my brother I
think it's extremely important because a
lot of us out there we're struggling
with the environment do you know what
the environment is all about it's a
hyper hyper hyper sexualized environment
everything you look at is advertising
the opposite sex that's what it is so
it's become so difficult you know even
if you click on a few hashtags for
example on Instagram you're bound to see
something that you're not supposed to be
looking at so you quickly don't look at
it you know it doesn't mean the first
look is yours so you know one of the
sheiks in Nigeria when we were there he
was giving an example he says you see
you have the phone and you know if you
see something that you're not supposed
to be looking at some of the people say
brother look at this now you know what I
still fear Allah stuff it on look at
that
oh you know look look look look at this
brother starving on la look my brother
chip look at this guy's looks though la
look look no no no no what one what it
means is you just say stuff for Allah
and you go to the next page or you
delete it or you stop it or whatever and
you put the phone down you don't keep on
looking at it thinking but it's just my
first look as they say that's your phone
take it easy you don't need to show the
world people forward it they will
forward a pornographic or a dirty
picture and right at the bottom of it a
password what's the password a start of
it all nah how can you do that you just
did something very bad you promoted evil
and you said the stuff Allah and you
think that that's acceptable no it's not
may Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala guide us
so maybe we can get to one of the
questions you have there Habibi one of
the questions well this is the third
question but I'm going to put it right
at the top because if there's aunties
and uncles they are and this is one of
the questions that I you know every time
I get an opportunity where I know
there's aunties and uncles listening
this is the question that I want to ask
and the reason why I want to ask is
because we have many questions as well
but one of these questions is regarding
couple of weeks ago brother messaged me
and said okay okay Marshall you talk
about how to protect yourself from Xena
etc but I want to do it the Halal way
the halal way is not possible for me
because my father or my mother is
rejecting a sister or a brother because
he's black or is why this even happens
with for example no offence Pakistanis
and Bangladeshis here I love you all may
Allah bless you guys with the same tribe
you know this I Somalians as well all
disrespect you know it's crazy because
it's like you're in the same tribe you
Somalian I'm like why they rejected
another Somalian not from my tribe so
this is the main question and one of the
biggest reasons which I believe from
what I've seen out there the the reason
why the youth take the rotors in are so
how could one pretend particular
themselves and what kind of advice would
you give to the parents who are making
it hard for the children to do it in a
halal way the marriage you know it's a
question that I've been a victim of
myself me too
confessions of sometime back mashallah
may Allah forgive them and forgive us I
look at it at hindsight and I say allahu
akbar perhaps we were meant to be you
know advising the parents my beloved
parents who are here and who will listen
to this later on if you have not
followed the method that allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala has taught you through
rasulullah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
when it comes to the marriage of your
children you've lost the plot you think
it's your child it's not it's a lost
child it's just a test for you the child
you think my child my child no way
you're just fortunate that a las allowed
you to say that for a moment he can take
the child away from you now and if he
wanted he wouldn't have even blessed you
with the child so don't think my child
tell yourself Amana from Allah will take
away any time will question me about how
I brought this Amana up and what I did
so them so the hadith Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam says either
otaku Montalban Edina whoo-whoo-whoo
Lucca hoof as the we do in latter I know
who Tekken fitna tone Velarde a facade
an area if someone comes to you wanting
to marry and they have proposed to marry
your child
they're two things are decent if you
don't allow that marriage muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam is telling
you there will be great fitna on earth
and facade you know what fitna and
facade means there will be trials
problems chaos calamity issues because
now you've encouraged sin so what are
these two things that Dean the Dean
meaning the level of religiousness the
level of closeness to Allah so something
decent they don't have to be someone saw
pious you know saw pious that you know
they've got to be in salat or tahajud
every day before I accept them dear dad
you don't even need to hide yourself so
stop it you know they must be totally
honest dad you lie as well I've caught
you lying so many times you know
sometimes stuff I shouldn't say this but
I feel like putting a CCTV in my own
home just to prove to people who live
with me sometimes you did say this
didn't you
you know the laughter means a lot of us
would love to do that
well Subhan Allah do it do it and say
that here it is
they will be so good quiet and tell them
those shakes you are a friend of I'm
going to show them how you operate in
the home they will be so upset what
about Allah Allah is watching all the
time you're not worried about allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala so if someone comes
to you the Deen is okay and the
character is okay they speak to you with
respect they're ready to respect your
child they have a sense of
responsibility let the marriage happen
let it happen so someone might say oh
but the hadith speaks about Khufu you
know what Khufu is it means they need to
be on a similar cultural line that's a
misinterpretation of the word you have
not interpreted the hadith correctly
you're talking of similarities in terms
of the upbringing so if you brought up
in London you've been to the similar
schools you've gone up you've had
similar upbringing you know what's
happening that's Khufu the color is
never an issue the tribe is not an issue
Bilal is not a BA was known as a lovely
Allah and what was he he was from Africa
subhanAllah
so Haber Rumi he was from Rome Subhan
Allah he was a white man
they were companions for a reason if
Allah wanted they wouldn't
in companions but they were companions
for us to learn a lesson later on to say
hang on hang on hang on do not be a
racist do not be a tribalist you come
from this tribe do you know a lot of us
and I'm going to say this to the older
people a lot of us even though we think
that we're not racist we are even though
we think we're not tribalist wallahi
search your heart you think the guys
from my village are slightly better than
the guys from that village what village
you're talking about you know the guys
from up north are a little bit backward
from the guys in London I don't know if
you've heard that you know we've got a
problem with people who come from
another area well lie in India there is
a river if you from the other side
you're a baddie and if you from this
side those people consider you a baddie
the same applies in the Philippines if
you come from the south you're tell us
you're somewhat on another level all
together why when the hadith speaks
clearly the verse of the Quran speaks
about Adam and how are being created
your forefathers subhanAllah you are all
from the family of the Prophet do you
know that everyone including myself we
are honored to be from the family of the
Prophet which prophet is the question
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala grant us an
understanding because new Hanna his
salat WA Salam is the closest common
grandfather whom we know for a fact was
our Father so aren't you from the family
of the Prophet more may Allah's peace
and blessings be upon him
there you are so if an African comes to
you to marry your daughter and you
happen to be for example Caucasian or
Asian and he tells you listen I would
like to get married to your daughter for
example look at his Deen and his who
look and see the interest of your child
because in Islam it is prohibited to
force your child to marry whom they do
not want to marry it's a major sin major
sin meaning you are you are going to
encourage so many other sins as a result
so remember this if someone comes to you
and your child your son your daughter
has a keen interest and they are so keen
for it and you happen to look at the
Deen and the whole of you
have to buy the instruction of Allah's
messenger let it happen if you don't
you're a racist you're the tribalist
Yura whatever else ist's and you know
what you're going to be caught by allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala a lot of people are
struggling struggling because they went
to school with someone they went to uni
with someone and so on and so forth and
later on they came the proper way please
come and see my dad and the poor fellow
comes to see the dad and the dad says no
why your skin tan is three point three
degrees more than mine I don't know if
tans are measured in degrees Habibi but
I just had to say it
okay degrees because of the heat you
know where you come from Africa like me
Subhan Allah
normally in Africa you find the hand is
very dark the reason is when you drive
you know you your hands are always burnt
so they look at your hand and say this
guy is extremely dark in complexion so
one guy says let me open my button cc'
okay now Allah forgive us
wallahi it's a problem it's got nothing
to do with the skin colour that tan I
come from Africa even among the African
sometimes they'll tell you a this
person's a little bit too dark hey we're
all Africans at the end of the day come
on
Subhan Allah we're all human beings
someone's got Deen and who look please
let it happen because you're going
against a line his rasul no but what are
people going to say what are people
going to say what is a lot going to say
the day what are you going to say the
day you dragged into a Hellfire I don't
want to sound like a prophet of doom but
for this thing there is a bit of doom
coming in your direction you know what
do means it's a spray you come across it
mashallah thirty minutes it is a
Caliphate you see the brother says three
minutes do you agree that the Quran says
al hasanat to be Ashley Anthony huh any
good deed is multiplied by ten you agree
isn't this a good deed so wouldn't you
like us to multiply the 3 by 10 so we
have 30 minutes Habibi jackal ahead I'm
- Allah you Thank You Allah bless you
answer the I was gonna ask you forced
marriages but humbly you covered that
brothers I will not leave the stage
until I've gone through these questions
inshallah yeah then one of the next
questions is
how how do I protect myself from dinner
I think the questions are related so how
do you protect yourself from Xena the
reality is number one number one
everyone listen to this it's not what
you think I'm going to say
shoot shoot shoot shoot